[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka die
ersten evakuierungsflüge der bundeswehr
haben heute rund 130 menschen aus kabul
ausgeflogen bislang jedenfalls das ist
gut für jede einzelne der geretteten
personen
doch es ist ein tropfen auf dem heißen
stein und fraglich wie viele afghanen
überhaupt noch eine chance auf rettung
haben der flughafen ist für sie kaum
noch zu erreichen die taliban
kontrollieren die zugänge und den
zivilen bereich des flughafens die
amerikaner halten nur noch den
militärischen teil zu wenig chaotischen
situationen das führt zeigte sich letzte
nacht die deutsche maschine stand auf
dem rollfeld mehrere afghanische
frauenrechtsaktivistin sollten
mitfliegen hatten es unter lebensgefahr
zum flughafen geschafft doch die us
soldaten ließen sie nicht rein ob jemand
auf einer deutschen liste steht zählte
nicht die zitat intensive abstimmung mit
unseren internationalen partnern von der
in berlin gerade so viel die rede ist
stellt man sich auch anders vor zur lage
heute in kabul mit
die wenigen bilder die noch in kabul
verbliebene medien liefern zeigen ein
unklares bild der situation
die taliban versuchen das öffentliche
leben wieder in gang zu bringen die
ordnung herzustellen
sie betonen niemand müsse angst haben
dass sie in viele menschen anders wie
der übersetzer osmann der für die
bundespolizei im land tätig war
wir bekamen eine telefonische warnung
dass die taliban wüssten wo sich halver
der deutschen aufhalten die auf ausreise
warten wir konnten uns glücklicherweise
in sicherheit bringen bevor sie kamen
zwar kündigten die machthaber eine
amnestie für regierungsbeamte und helfer
ausländische organisationen an doch vor
allem frauen sehen mit furcht in die
zukunft
die situation ist jetzt nicht normal
alle haben angst und viele verschanzen
sich so gut es geht in ihren häusern
die neuen herren in kabul wissen um die
macht der bilder im fernsehinterview mit
einer journalistin geben sie sich offen
und persönlich bei der ersten
pressekonferenz bestätigte ein taliban
sprecher man sei in verhandlungen zur
bildung einer übergangsregierung es
werde keine racheakte geben der krieg
sei beendet und auch frauen müssten sich
keine sorgen machen
frauen werden alle rechte zugestanden
bei der arbeit oder anderswo sind teil
der gesellschaft im rahmen des islam
die umsetzung dieser ankündigung könnte
nach ansicht von beobachtern zu brüchen
bei den taliban führen konflikte
vorprogrammiert
die taliban behaupten viel und viel
gegensätzliches bislang konnten sie sich
das erlauben jetzt müssen sie liefern
sie wollen bei frauenrechten flexibler
sein sagt die führung was wenn ihre
kämpfer genau das nicht rollen werden
sie dann den anweisungen noch folgen
oder sagen sie dann dafür haben wir
nicht gekämpft
nach presseberichten nahmen heute
bereits erste regierungsbeamte ihre
arbeit wieder auf aber keine frauen
während jetzt hektisch versucht wird zu
retten wer noch zu retten ist stehen
weiter viele brennende fragen im raum
wie konnte dieser einsatz nach 20 jahren
so unrühmlich enden dass die lage in
afghanistan völlig falsch eingeschätzt
wurde ist nur eine seite des desasters
das erklärt nicht warum nicht wenigstens
in den letzten wochen als die taliban
anfing eine provinz nach der anderen
einzunehmen hochgradig gefährdete
afghanen auf der falle geholt wurden an
der sie jetzt sitzen sollte die große
koalition im wahlkampf alles vermeiden
was eine flüchtlings debatte auslösen
könnte wenn dem so war so ist ihr das
jetzt schwer auf die füße gefallen
andrea maurer zur politischen debatte in
berlin
es ist ein ikonisches foto das das
pentagon veröffentlicht hat und das in
bitterem kontrast zum ersten deutschen
evakuierungs flug steht während am
sonntag 640 menschen in einer
amerikanischen militärmaschine zuflucht
finden hebt der a400m der deutschen
gestern abend mit nur sieben evakuierten
an bord ab die lage sei äußerst
gefährlich gewesen die
verteidigungsministerin verspricht nun
so viele menschen wie möglich zu retten
mit der einschränkung so lange es geht
so lange es irgendwie möglich ist
fliegen wir in dem maße wie es irgendwie
möglich ist menschen aus kabul heraus
vor allem die chancen die vielen
ortskräfte zu evakuieren stehen schlecht
im internen lagebericht des
verteidigungsministeriums heißt es mit
der abriegelung des flughafens
ermöglichen die taliban den
internationalen kräften zunehmend einen
geordneten flugverkehr zur evakuierung
ihrer staatsangehörigen einzurichten
gleichzeitig wird jedoch durch die
abriegelung des flughafens für
afghanische staatsbürger eine
evakuierung ehemaliger afghanischer
ortskräfte erschwert der deutsche
botschafter in kabul soll nun in
gesprächen mit den taliban
ausreisemöglichkeiten für ortskräfte
verhandeln immer drängender die frage ob
die bundesregierung die lage zu lange
falsch eingeschätzt hat tatsache ist
dass es kein szenario gab erstens dass
die taliban so schnell vorangehen
zweitens dass sie auch blitzschnell den
flughafen abriegeln und offensichtlich
nur ausländer in anführungszeichen
rauslassen keine eigenen leute das hätte
man einkalkulieren können hinter steht
sicher auch die sorge dass wenn man die
ortskräfte das ist ein anderes thema
rechtzeitig genommen hätte dass man dann
wieder eine migrationswelle ausgelöst
hätte und es gibt ja einen breiten
konsens dass man 2015 nicht wieder ohne
wolle und möchte und ich glaube das hat
mit zu diesem zögerlichen entscheidungen
in berlin maßgeblich beigetragen
es geht nun auch um die frage der
politischen verantwortung wie hat es zu
solchen szenen kommen können der
bundespräsident schaut auf die bilder
von kabul und das größere bild die
bilder der verzweiflung am
flughafen kabul sind beschämend für den
politischen westen wir erleben in diesen
tagen eine menschliche tragödie für die
wir mitverantwortung tragen und eine
politische zäsur
die uns erschüttert und die welt
verändern wird
bilder der erleichterung dagegen am
nachmittag am flughafen von taschkent
125 weitere menschen hat die bundeswehr
evakuiert und die bilder selbst
veröffentlicht
und das beliebtestes jetzt der
bundesaußenminister zugeschaltet guten
abend herr maas aus russland der
bundespräsident sagte eben das ist
beschämend für sie sich beschämt oder
schämen sie sich als mitglied der
bundesregierung
wenn man die bilder in afghanistan sieht
sind die gefühle die dabei selber beim
ausgelöst wird alles andere als schön
kenne viele dieser menschen in den
letzten drei jahren bin ich auch selber
in afghanistan gewesen ich bin dort
gewesen wo jetzt die taliban sitzen im
präsidentenpalast wir haben viele
befreundete
nichtregierungsorganisationen
frauenrechtler
menschenrechtsaktivisten unterstützt
deren schicksal berührt uns alle
das lässt uns auch nicht wohnen und
deshalb haben wir alles in die wege zu
leiten um den menschen zu helfen so
vieles gilt nur deren schicksal hat in
den letzten wochen und monaten
anscheinend nicht so berührt dass dort
wirklich geholfen wurde sind jede menge
ortskräfte die wurden nicht rausgeholt
es wurden die visa-anträge verzögert wir
kennen einen mann 34 dolmetscher in
masar i scharif der hat selbst noch
kabul geschafft hat sich auch keiner
darum gekümmert der rennt jetzt mit frau
und zwei kleinen kindern durch die
parkanlagen in kabul und das einfach nur
noch ein panik was sagen sie den
wir haben eine entscheidung getroffen
was er 2500 ortskräfte die ausreise nach
deutschland genehmigen das sind
diejenigen gewesen die unmittelbar für
die bundeswehr gearbeitet haben und
diese entscheidung haben wir getroffen
in einer situation in der zwar das
militär abgezogen worden ist aber in der
niemand damit gerechnet hat dass die
taliban so schnell kabul einnehmen das
ist offensichtlich eine fehleinschätzung
gewesen
und nachdem wir uns das eingestehen
mussten haben wir den kreis derjenigen
erweitert die wir ohne visa ohne
sicherheitsprüfung jetzt schnell nach
deutschland bringen wollen das ist die
evakuierungsaktion die jetzt angelaufen
ist und es ist gerade im moment in kabul
ein zweiter flieger gestartet mit 139
personen an bord die zusätzlich zu dem
ersten flieger von heute
weiterhin
in kabul in masar i scharif in kundus
und die haben keine chance gehabt auf
visa obwohl die reisepässe hatten obwohl
sie antragsberechtigt gewesen sind es
wurde immer wieder verzögert es gab auch
gar keine stellen wo die hin konnten das
hat kein einziger dieser prozess nach
dieser erweiterung im juni stattgefunden
da wurde gar nicht erst begonnen dann
wollte die leute nicht ja das kann ich
ganz sein fonds long körper ansonsten
werden nicht 1900 leute mittlerweile in
deutschland mit einem ausgestellten
visum und zwar nach der entscheidung die
wir getroffen haben 2500 von den
ehemaligen orts kräften zu uns nach
deutschland zu nehmen für diejenigen um
die es jetzt geht werden überhaupt keine
visa mehr benötigt das heißt die visa
werden erst ausgestellt wenn die leute
schon in deutschland sind es werden auch
keine sicherheitsüberprüfung mehr
durchgeführt auch die wird in
deutschland durchgeführt das heißt es
sind alle voraussetzungen dafür
geschaffen wurden dass wir jetzt jeden
tag mit so wie heute zwei maschinen
hunderte von menschen aus fliegen können
und wir werden das morgen auch so
fortsetzen aber dass das ist eine
fehleinschätzung gegeben hat das
streitet doch niemand mehr an diese
menschen müssen noch überhaupt erstmal
zum flughafen kommen der wird
kontrolliert von taliban diese menschen
schmeißen im moment alles weg was
irgendwie nach kontakten zu deutschland
oder so aussieht weil das furchtbar
gefährlich ist auch von ihren handys
löschen die kontakte wie sollen die dann
noch belegen dass sie die ortskräfte
sind weil sie schon registriert sind
über die organisation die sie für die
sie gearbeitet haben
diese sind zusammengefasst wurden and
listen die sind in den ministerien etwa
im entwicklungshilfeministerium wo die
entwicklungshilfe organisiert wurde und
entwicklungsorganisationen gearbeitet
haben aufgenommen worden sind wir
befinden uns auch in kontakt mit diesen
menschen das ist auch notwendig um in
eine information zu geben
ab wann sie an den flughafen kommen so
wie wir es mit den deutschen
staatsbürgern heute gemacht haben und
darüber sprechen wir mit den usa aber
darüber spricht auch botschafter puzzle
der heute in doha angekommen ist mit den
taliban um die voraussetzungen zu
schaffen dass auch ortskräfte ausreisen
das ist lagen der langen rolle punkten
vorbei gelassen werden was bisher nicht
der fall und kann andere kann dann
werden wir auch nicht durchgelassen die
amerikaner haben gesagt dass sie
zunächst ihre staatsangehörigen aus
fliegen und danach die ortskräfte sowohl
ihre eigenen als auch die von
partnerorganisationen der nato im moment
sind die amerikaner aber noch dabei ihre
eigenen staatsbürger auszufliegen
dann schauen wir mal ob unsere man an
den ich im moment gerade denke der durch
den park los mit zwei kleinen
schreienden kindern um der bis dahin
überlebt bisher kontaktiert wurde und
bis man ihn zum flughafen nutzt die wir
kennen auch leute die haben es heute zum
flughafen geschafft und wurden wieder
nach hause geschickt also wir haben hier
heute den leuten den wir eine
information gegeben haben zutritt zum
flughafen was schafft es sind zwei 180
leute da von denen haben wir jetzt in
der zweiten maschine gerade eben
139 ausgeflogen es steht eine weitere
maschine zur verfügung
im moment sind die tore am flughafen
geschlossen und sobald die wieder
geöffnet sind werden wir diesen betrieb
fortsetzen genauso wie das heute gemacht
haben und ich bin froh dass das jetzt
endlich angelaufen ist trotz aller
schwierigkeiten die situation ist nach
wie vor extrem schwierig aber zumindest
können flugzeuge landen und starten und
damit auch menschen evakuiert werden man
hätte das alles sehr viel einfacher
machen können wenn man damit schon ein
paar wochen vorher angefangen hätte die
afghanen wussten wie gefährlich ist es
die sind schon im juni als die deutschen
truppen abgezogen auch wenn es irgendwie
ging aus masar i scharif ein kunde ist
zum beispiel geflohen oder haben sich
oder haben sie die geräte haben kabul
sei sicher und das ist die
fehleinschätzung die die komplette
internationale
gemeinschaft die bundesregierung ich
unsere dienste aber auch viele
afghaninnen und afghanen
hatten sie dachten kabul wird sich
länger halten das ist nicht der fall
gewesen und es nützt auch nichts dass in
irgendeiner weise kleinzureden das ist
nicht zu beschönigen
und deshalb setzen wir jetzt alles daran
um zumindest denjenigen die da sind die
sind ja alle nach kabul zu bekommen auch
die außen alle noch zu ermöglichen nicht
nur wir die amerikaner fliegen aus und
viele andere partnerstaaten in kunduz
sitzen auch noch viele aber da sie
sagten man konnte damit nicht rechnen
warum hat denn ihr botschafter damit
gerechnet das ist immer schlimmer wird
warum hat der schon beschriebenen seit
wochen versuchen wir irgendwie um hilfe
zu bitten der botschafter hat darauf
hingewiesen sie die wie die situation in
der botschaft ist und der botschafter
hat am letzten freitag in einer
besprechung des krisenstabes erklärt
dass auch in der botschaft die
sicherheit kurzfristig gewährleistet ist
und das hat dazu geführt dass wir den
evakuierungsplan in gang gesetzt haben
im übrigen wie alle anderen botschaften
auch dann sind unsere
botschaftsmitarbeiter die heute abend in
berlin angekommen sind am sonntag auch
ausgeflogen worden genauso wie andere
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter anderer
botschaften das ist genau so gelaufen
wie bei anderen staaten wir sind auch
darauf einstellen sind gewissen dass die
mitarbeiter der botschaft dageblieben
sind sonst hätten wir überhaupt kein
visum ausstellen können sonst ja
überhaupt keine orts kraft ein fluch
deshalb hätte ich diese entscheidung die
würde ich jederzeit genau so wieder
treffen warum hat dann ihr
stellvertretender botschafter
beschrieben dass an irgendeiner stelle
diesmal schief gehen sollte so wäre dies
vermeidbar gewesen weil den dringenden
appellen der botschaft über längere zeit
erst in dieser woche abhilfe geschaffen
wird die botschaft hat darauf
hingewiesen dass sich die lage
verschlechtert hat und das ist doch von
niemandem abgestritten wurden wir werden
aber immer in den besprechungen des
krisenstabes auch andere informationen
berücksichtigen müssen wie die des
bundesnachrichtendienstes aber es ist ja
nichts geschehen alle bot alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sind in
sicherheit sie sind in deutschland
mittlerweile ein kernteam ist in kabul
am flughafen und hilft jetzt
auszufliegen ich bin den kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr dankbar aber es wird hier
getan als wenn irgendjemand zu schaden
gekommen ist es ist nicht der fall wir
haben in weiß magath vor allem wie
andere länder auch unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
evakuiert und aber haben wir haben er
war kurz sondern die amerikaner haben
letztendlich unsere botschaft vielleicht
daran er scheine kaufen weil nur die
deutsche regierung eine entscheidung
darüber treffen können ob die deutsche
botschaft evakuiert wird oder nicht das
entscheiden auch nicht die amerikaner
aber wir hatten lange vorher mit den
amerikaner geplantes wenn eine solche
evakuierung stattfindet mit
amerikanischen hubschraubern von der
botschaft der usa die kolleginnen und
kollegen an den flughafen gebracht
werden das ist auch nicht nur bei den
deutschen botschaftsangehörigen so
gewesen sondern auch bei denen anderer
starten und wie erklären sie sich dass
der nachrichtendienst ihre geheimdienste
das bundesverteidigungsministerium dass
da irgendwie niemand wusste dass das
spätestens wenn kundus fällt doch
irgendwie ganz schön eng wird
ich kann ja nicht mehr als wiederholen
die fehleinschätzung die es in dem
zusammenhang gegeben hat die haben alle
getroffen ansonsten hätte ist ja diese
große fehleinschätzung ja nicht nur in
deutschland sondern international auch
nicht gegeben wir haben ja keinen
deutschen sonderweg gewählt sondern wir
haben die information die wir hatten mit
unseren partnern abgeglichen und die
waren so dass sie uns die grundlage
dafür geliefert haben diese situation so
einzuschätzen wie sie bedauerlicherweise
am schluss nicht gewesen ist
sagt man die dienste waren blind politik
unterlag einer massiven fehleinschätzung
die leute wurden nicht rausgeholt weil
dieser prozessor verzögert worden weil
man sich auch nicht hier haben wollte
aber dann irgendjemand dafür ist
politischer prozesse verzögert worden
sind es sind doch von den
2500 für die wir uns entschieden haben
die ortskräfte der bundeswehr die visa
erteilt wurden 1900 sind in deutschland
die andere haben auf anderem wege
afghanistan verlassen oder haben von der
möglichkeit nicht gebrauch gemacht ist
leider gar nicht an den visa dass es die
leute ja auch nicht hier und für die um
die es jetzt geht waren ja eine wiese
mehr als viele waren ja erst ab juni
anfrage überhaupt erst die möglichkeit
anträge zu stellen weil das da erst
erweitert wurde und dann konnten es aber
auch wiederum nur solche die zum
beispiel eine gefährdung sun zeige
gestellt also unglaubliche bürokratische
monster dann gab es keine stelle wo sie
in kabul hingehen konnten also der mann
um zum anfang unseres gespräches
zurückzukommen der hässlichen park läuft
wir hatten reisepass aber der saß fünf
wochen lang in diesem safe house und es
gab keine möglichkeit eine lesung zu
beantragen obwohl antragsberechtigt ist
die wie ein visum für die 2.500 ist ja
erteilt worden und für alle darüber
hinaus dafür bedarf es überhaupt kein
visum
ist aber schreiben von den ältesten
bruchs verteidigungsministerium gemacht
hat und die für die bundeswehr dort
gearbeitet haben haben alle ihr visum
bekommen die haben alle auch die
gefährdungs prüfung durchlaufen und von
denen sind 1904 ist geht doch jetzt um
diejenigen für die es bis dahin
überhaupt keine entscheidung gegeben hat
dass wir nach deutschland kommen sollten
und der zeitpunkt hat doch etwas damit
zu tun dass am vierten juli die
internationale truppenpräsenz in
afghanistan beendet worden ist bis dahin
gab es auch von dort keinerlei keinerlei
nachfragen und keinerlei
entwicklungen auch in anderen ländern
die dazu geführt hätten dass man im
großen stil leute aus afghanistan raus
bringt das ist durch die entscheidung
der amerikaner in gang gesetzt wurden
und der zeitpunkt ab dem das virulent
war ist der zeitpunkt ab dem die
internationalen truppen abgezogen waren
und das ist der vierte juli gewesen also
wie viele truppen am ende wie viele
leute da nicht raus geholt wurden und
wie viele visa gewartet haben und keine
möglichkeit der zweiten das ist ein
kompliziertes thema das wird auch noch
sicherlich auch von uns noch mal ein
gründlicher nach gearbeitet und ich
danken aber für das gespräch
von deutschland aus mit anzusehen was
jetzt in afghanistan geschieht das ist
natürlich am schlimmsten für alle die
dort familie und freunde haben die
täglich mit menschen telefonieren die um
ihr leben fürchten in panik sind und
zutiefst deprimiert weil sie genau
wissen was aus ihrem land unter den
taliban wird romero rhein hat mit
afghanen in hamburg gesprochen
hamburg st georg hier in der nähe des
hauptbahnhofs kaufen täglich viele
afghanen in den geschäften ihrer
landsleute ein wie blicken sie auf die
entwicklungen in ihrer heimat
ich stehe genau wie alle afghanen
momentan unter schock die bilder von
menschen die von einem flugzeug stürzen
wer kann so etwas ertragen stellen sie
sich vor afghanen sind auch menschen
sind wir nur auf die welt gekommen um
getötet zu werden
das beschäftigt mich schon sehr wohl ich
geboren bin und
tiefen einfach
ich bin im krieg geboren und im krieg
aufgewachsen meine eltern sind immer
noch in afghanistan
nachts kriege ich kaum ein auge zu die
situation ist einfach schrecklich wir
afghanen können uns doch gar nicht als
mensch fühlen es ist als seien wir
überflüssige wiesen aber auch wir sind
menschen auch wir haben gefühle
die jungen männer sind die einzigen die
mit uns gesprochen haben alle anderen
haben abgelehnt aus sorge um ihre
angehörigen in der heimat
auch miriam natur hat noch familie im
land nach mehreren versuchen endlich
eine verbindung zu ihrem cousin in kabul
der von chaotischen zuständen berichtet
dinge des alltäglichen bedarf seien kaum
zu kriegen
die täglichen gespräche mit ihrer
familie wenigstens eine möglichkeit um
zu zeigen dass sie an sie denkt und
damit vielleicht ein kleines bisschen
trost spenden kann ist es so eine
mischung von wut trauer
auch nicht wirklich was machen zu können
das alles natürlich sich anzugucken über
videos fotos im austausch miriam natur
und jammer war sie arbeiten gemeinsam
für einen hilfsverein für geflüchtete
ihr kollege sorgt sich vor allem um die
kinder viele von ihnen hätten ihre
eltern verloren und seien völlig auf
sich allein gestellt das möchte ich von
der politik gerade von den deutschen
dass sie sagen nein wir bleiben am ball
und wir werden einfach mit den taliban
oder mit der afghanischen regierung
weiter für die werte und rechte der
menschen vor ort weiter verhandeln diese
bilder sind noch kein jahr alt
glückliche mädchen in einer neu gebauten
schule in kabul ein projekt des vereins
für den e la lima in hamburg arbeitet
die gebürtige afghanin erinnert an die
zeit ab 1996 als die taliban mädchen vom
schulsystem ausgeschlossen haben
wir haben natürlich die sorge dass die
mädchen nicht mehr zur schule kommen
dass die schulen tatsächlich auch wieder
geschlossen werden auch unsere projekte
geschlossen werden
aber ob das so passiert es wissen wir
nicht die zukunft afghanistans ist
ungewiss so wie schon seit über 40
jahren und
jetzt gibt es erstmal andere nachrichten
des tages der heinz wolf nach dem
schweren erdbeben im süden haitis haben
die menschen dort auch noch mit
regenmengen zu kämpfen die ein
tropensturm in die region gebracht hat
mehr als 1400 menschen sind bei dem
beben ums leben gekommen zehntausende
häuser sind zerstört oder beschädigt
besonders stark betroffen ist die stadt
legt
menschen suchen vor dem tropensturm
notdürftig schutz unter provisorischen
zelten nicht standhielt die klinik der
stadt hatte die verletzten draußen
behandelt im regen und sturm dann
drängten sie sich trennen der sturm ist
zwischen weitergezogen berichte über
neue schäden oder verletzte als folge
des unwetters gab es zunächst nicht
wenn sie den opfern des erdbebens helfen
wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet die bahn lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 das stichwort zdf
nothilfe haiti weitere informationen
finden sie unter spendenprojekt zdf de
oder im text auf seite 8 190
nach deutschland und zur coroner lage
das robert koch institut meldet 3912
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind
1432 mehr als vor einer woche 28
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei
37,4
die cdu-fraktion im von der
hochwasserkatastrophe schwer getroffenen
kreis ahrweiler drängt auf einen wie es
in einer erklärung heißt unbelasteten
personellen neuanfang in der führung
sandra köhler gegen den die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittlungen
eingeleitet hat übt sein amt laut der
erklärung derzeit krankheitsbedingt
nicht aus die flutkatastrophe ist morgen
auch thema im kreistag und dabei soll es
auch um landrat pföhler gehen
im tarifkonflikt zwischen der bahn und
der gewerkschaft deutscher
lokomotivführer müssen reisende neue
einschränkungen im bahnverkehr
befürchten der chef der gdl weselsky
drohte bei einer kundgebung vor der bahn
zentrale in berlin wird streiks sollte
die bahn kein neues angebot machen die
gdl werde diesmal aber frühzeitiger
darüber informieren die bahn forderte
die gewerkschaft erneut auf die
tarifverhandlungen wieder aufzunehmen
menschen in einer flutkatastrophe
fotografiert in den momenten in denen
ihnen das ganze ausmaß bewusst wird dass
alles was sie hatten vernichtet ist und
ihnen dieses greifen ins gesicht
geschrieben steht der fotograf gideon
mendel macht solche bilder seit vielen
jahren sie sind teil seines politischen
engagements die folgen des klimawandels
aufzuzeigen er ist dafür immer wieder um
die ganze welt gereist und im juli nach
deutschland in die hochwassergebiete für
die zeit hat er dort flog auch vor
porträtiert christina berichtet
fotograf gediehen mendl ist zum zweiten
mal in stolberg er ist aus
großbritannien angereist um noch einmal
die menschen zu treffen die er für eine
zeitung zehn tage nach der katastrophe
porträtiert hat auch christoph krümmel
und ramona mainz gehören dazu ihr
friseur salon wurde von der flut
komplett zerstört
ich bin von oben runter geschaut hatten
hat man echt auch so ein riesen ja
baumstumpf herunter fließen sehen dass
unsere rein und wieder raus
den beiden ist die existenzgrundlage
weggebrochen der salon war ihr zweites
zuhause erst zögerten sie als gm mendel
sie fotografieren wollte doch dann haben
sie ihm die erlaubnis dafür gegeben sehr
schön zu sehen dass sich jemand für sag
ich mal
das was passiert ist interessiert
gleichzeitig ist es natürlich immer
wieder auch anstrengender zu gehen da
hab ich ganz ehrlich sein die eigene
geschichte erzählen nicht vergessen
werden die dirndl weiß dass viele nach
einer katastrophe dieses bedürfnis haben
die menschen wollen dass ihre
erfahrungen mit anderen geteilt werden
sie wollen vom rest der welt gesehen
werden
und den menschen kennt viele schicksale
wie die aus stolberg seit 14 jahren
bereist er die welt und fotografiert
menschen die von naturkatastrophen
betroffen sind darunter auch viele
flutopfer zentriert im bild schauen sie
die betrachter eindringlich an trotz
aller verzweiflung würde voll und stolz
ich habe so viele geflutete häuser
fotografiert zb in texas häuser von
multimillionär und den reichsten leuten
der welt und auch die ärmsten in
bangladesch oder nigeria und das was
mich erstaunt hat ist dass alle etwas
miteinander verbindet nämlich ihre
verletzlichkeit
der mensch und sein besitz im angesicht
von naturgewalten ist alles hab und gut
plötzlich zweitrangig was zählt ist oft
nur das eigene überleben
genau diese erfahrung hat auch familie
akte aus stolberg machen müssen die flut
kam so plötzlich dass sie sich nicht
mehr aus dem haus retten konnten über
sieben stunden verbrachten sie auf ihrer
fensterbank in todesangst
immer öfter altgeräten mendel mit seiner
kamera zu waldbränden oder fluten auf
der ganzen welt für ihn ist die häufung
dieser katastrophen ein klares zeichen
des klimawandels
ich glaube wir sind halt an dem
zentralen und auch schwierigen punkt der
menschheitsgeschichte nacken tempel
hästrägern für meine zukunft und auch
die meiner kinder muss ich tun was in
meiner macht steht und die wenigen
fähigkeiten die ich habe einsetzen um
damit ein städten versetzen
die menschen die er trifft hinterlassen
in ihm tiefe spuren die am ende zeigt
sie in einem moment schmerzliche
erkenntnis in dem moment in dem sie
erkennen dass die natur stärker ist als
sie
[Musik]
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit anderen
themen die umweltorganisation wwf sieht
in deutschland noch großes potenzial bei
der vermeidung und wiederverwertung von
plastikmüll gefordert wird dafür ein
zusammenspiel von industrie politik und
wissenschaft sowie ein umdenken in der
gesellschaft
frank bethmann wie sieht die wirtschaft
das thema ja es mag überraschen aber
dass sie die wirtschaft ziemlich genau
so ein sehr viel stärkere einstieg in
eine kreislaufwirtschaft würde viele
probleme lösen zwar attestiert der wwf
deutschland eine ruhe sammelquote doch
das reicht nicht jährlich würden 1,6
millionen tonnen kunststoff verpackungen
mit einem gesamtwert von 3,8 milliarden
euro verbrannt fand systeme müssten her
jenseits des getränke systems nach für
konzepte in supermärkten beispielsweise
denn fast 60 prozent des deutschen
kunststoffe abfalls entsteht durch ein
weg artikel und verpackungen das noch
viel zu viel von dem plastik müll
verbrannt wird ist ein riesen
umweltproblem doch es verursacht eben
auch enorme kosten und führt in nicht
notwendige abhängigkeit in deutschland
ist ein rohstoffarmes land seit monaten
sprechen wir von bedrohlichen
lieferengpässen all das könnte weiterhin
vermieden werden würde es gelingen die
verwendeten materialien viel länger als
bisher im wirtschaftskreislauf zu halten
bis 2040 könnte deutschland 20 millionen
tonnen kunststoff einsparen weil sehr
viel konsequenter im recycling so die
wwf studie der einstieg in eine
kreislaufwirtschaft könnte also
rohstoffe und kosten sparen und dem
klimaschutz dienen alles dinge auf die
inzwischen auch die finanzmärkte sehr
viel wert legen frank bethmann vielen
dank
nach der flutwelle in der höllental
klarmann der zugspitze ist eine frau tot
aus dem wasser geborgen worden die suche
nach einer zweiten vermissten person
wurde mittlerweile vorerst eingestellt
beide hatten laut augenzeugen auf einer
brücke in der bei wanderern beliebten
klamm gestanden die durch die flutwelle
weggerissen worden seien acht menschen
waren nach dem unglück gestern
weitgehend unverletzt aus der klamm in
sicherheit gebracht worden
was lassen uns gleich nach dem wetter
folgt die reportage reihe 37 grad und um
0.30 gibt es dann unser heutigen update
mit anna maria schuck und uns morgen
wieder auf wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]
guten abend zwischen dem tief luciano
und den neuen hochs violine bleiben wir
weiterhin in einer nordwestströmung das
bedeutet für uns eher wechselhaftes
wetter viele wolken zwischendurch auch
mal etwas sonne aber eben auch
regenschauer und das bedeutet auch es
bleibt vorerst relativ kühl das sehen
sie hier auch ganz schön sie sehen hier
dieses sturmtief sie sehen das daran
dass sie so waren also die linien
gleichen luftdrucks hier recht eng
gedrängt sind und das -tief jetzt vor
allen dingen morgen dann schon
skandinavien erreicht haben wird heute
nacht gibt es noch kräftigen wind vor
allen dingen an der ostsee da sind doch
noch einige schauer unterwegs und es
fällt regen ungefähr zwischen dem
niederrhein und dem alpenrand die
temperaturen sinken in dieser nacht im
osten meist auf 11 ist 9 grad etwas
milder bleibt es im norden und im westen
da geht auf 14 bis 11 grad runter und
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
hier im fichtelgebirge nur so bei 16
grad in der leipziger tiefland bucht
dagegen wird es am mildesten 22 grad und
auch morgen vormittag fällt noch regen
in diesem streifen ungefähr vom
sauerland bis zur donau
das wird sich dann am nachmittag ändern
dann lockern die wolken immer mehr auf
und vor allem im südwesten sehen sie
dann häufiger die sonne die regenwolken
hier in norddeutschland die sind
allerdings relativ zäh und die halten
sich auch noch in den nächsten tagen
dann aber neben noch die sonnen anteile
mehr und mehr zu und es wird auch wärmer
guten abend